wait that was my dream last night what I
was in a car with Whitney Cummings and
she was like I'm having paa this
excessive um craving for deep fried
cockroaches well she's like can you keep
a secret and she was just chowing down
in her car and she was like will you
have one with me I'm like no thank you
that's where you know it's not the real
Whitney because Whitney herself can keep
no secrets there would have been no
secrets she would have been on her story
being like I'm also shocked in your
dream you weren't like excited to have
it with her I'm terrified of cockroaches
oh right but oh even eat I thought you
eat all bugs sorry I'm
sorry download the DraftKings casino app
now sign up with promo code trash
Tuesday and new customers get a deposit
match up to $100 in Casino credits when
you deposit $5 or more only on
DraftKings casino with promo code trash
Tuesday Andy you're a Vegas girl right
I'm a Vegas girl baby but sometimes I
can't get there you like the slot
machines love the slot machines I have
Blackjack goes too fast for me honestly
did you know that you can step into a
world of non-stop action on DraftKings
casino and play the classics like
Blackjack roulette and Slots plus enjoy
exclusive games you can't find anywhere
else and right now new customers can get
a deposit match up to
$100 in Casino credits when you deposit
$5 or more all you have to do is sign up
select the offer make your deposit and
start playing from a full sweet of games
DraftKings is safe secure and reliable
you can deposit and withdraw your cash
whenever you're ready did you guys know
you don't need to be able to read play
DraftKings I'm a lot better at
DraftKings than I am reading download
the DraftKings casino app now sign up
with promo code trash Tuesday and new
customers get a deposit match up to $100
in Casino credits when you deposit $5 or
more only on DraftKings casino with
promo code trash Tuesday gambling
problem call 1 1800 Gambler Michigan New
Jersey Pennsylvania West Virginia please
play responsibly in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at charl toown races in
West Virginia all games regulated by the
West Virginia lottery in Connecticut
help is available for problem G gambling
call 8887895118
[Music]
W Virginia only void in Ontario one per
opted in customer minimum $5 deposit ma
Max match $100 in Casino credits which
require onetime playr within 7 Days see
terms at casino. draftkings.com SL
players choice restriction Supply void
in Ontario one per opted in new customer
minimum $5 deposit match Max match $100
in Casino credits which require onetime
play through Within 7 Days hi you guys
so for 20% off your first order and a
free gram of
thca flour go to hello.com and use promo
code trash Tuesday that's hell o
o.com promo code trash Tuesday for 20%
off your order and a free gram of thca
flour you guys mood is known for their
federally legal THC but now they're
adding their most potent product yet to
the lineup introducing hemp based thca
flour the future of legal THC try it
along with all of mood's other amazing
offerings like Delta 8 flour gummies
Vape cartridges and more I know
personally I love a vape I can take it
with me anywhere it's
discreet that's kind of my current go-to
and for a limited time mood is giving
our listeners a free gram of thca flour
and 20% off your first order just visit
hello.com and use our code trash Tuesday
mood's latest and most potent
breakthrough in the world of legal
cannabis is thca flowers since thca
converts into THC when you heat it you
get you get access to the classic
marijuana High did you know that Andy
okay I like it doesn't count and mood
has 10 high inducing strains the most
potent they've ever offered so now is
the time to try baby try mood's new thca
flour today and for 20% off your first
order and a free gram of thca flour go
to hello.com and use promo code trash
Tuesday that's hell
o.com promo code trash Tuesday for 20%
off your order and a free gram of thca
flour give your hair the detox it needs
with living proof visit living proof.com
Tuesday and use code trash Tuesday to
get 15% off your first purchase that's
livingproof
docomoofficial code trash Tuesday Annie
do you ever deal with split ends dry
scalp breakage um usually this is
something that would make people panic
but let's talk about living proof it's
founded by an unlikely combination of
MIT biotech scientists and renowned hair
stylists living proof passion for
brilliant healthy hair starts with an
Innovative and scientific approach to
solving your hair's toughest challenges
I do love a hair product that uh went to
college you know what I mean and our
favorite is their dry shampoo
oh I love that dry shampoo in fact
there's no other dry shampoo as far as
it works great for texture it works
great for you know
deifying and I wish I had some right now
for what I'm looking at thank you so
much for your honesty I did just eat mac
and cheese it's not my fault and not
only does living proof have more than
300 Awards but you can count on their
products to be formulated without
silicon SLS and SLE sulfates parabens
and phalates plus living proof is also
pea certified cruelty Fe free color safe
and safe for chemically treated hair
living proof is their dry shampoo is
really the only dry shampoo I use I've
tried every dry shampoo it cannot cut my
grease I don't know if I have an extra
greasy scalp or what but you do
oh that's just what uh a little birdie
told me everyone tells it everyone's
been talking about my scalp people are
talking I'm so embarrassed no but I love
I mean living proof's awesome give your
hair the detox it needs with living
proof visit living proof.com Tuesday and
use code trash Tuesday to get 15% off
your first purchase that's livingproof
docomoofficial and November 16th at
irine improv can't wait to see you guys
get tickets at eser on i.com yo yo what
up sluggy I am on the road I am having
fun I am filming my special soon so my
set is tight it is so cute and I'm so
excited to perform for you and meeting
you in the meet and greets absolutely
rules you can see me next November 17th
and 18th at the San Jose Improv I'll be
in Houston Texas at the Houston Improv
December 15th through 17th I'll be in
Edmonton the at the comic strip in
Alberta Canada January 12th and 13th and
I'll be in Jacksonville Florida at the
comedy zone January 19th and 20th more
dates are always added so go to Annie
letter.com shows and I'll see you in
annwood on Thursdays um you guys Welcome
to our Y2K early 2000 themed episode
which really every episode should be
that theme um but we got one in the can
right now so welcome we're all in our
juicy sweatsuits I will say I've already
worn this on just randomly on the show
so yes thank you you''ve worn the pink
one the tan one guys I've been trapped
okay they say you dressed the year you
were oh no they don't we're not going to
say those words anymore because we're
not getting
demonetized um well and I've rocked some
like lowrise Von Dutch oh that's right
no you had to come back with the most
disrespectful of the trends low rise is
back it's not it's not me but who are
these it's like that's why OA came out
and then they're like okay now we can do
lowrise again that's interesting in
correlation that you found you're not
wrong what's the equivalent for guys are
they going to come back with like the
flor de like bedazzle Affliction jenos I
want jenos
badage jeno jenos I feel like have never
really never really went away do you
guys know who Brandon durmer is no yeah
I do actually he and I his his
aunt walks the neighborhood with my mom
sometimes oh that's right he's from
Chicago
that makes sense she's like I know
him who is he who is he that's so sweet
that your mom's walk with each other my
mom and his aunt but yes oh his aunt oh
that's so sweet so you don't know him
it's very far removed some snacks for
you guys to 2000 really snacks we have
to reach in it's oh my goodness scary my
my most popular personal 2000 snack was
eating the cookie dough that we sold for
choir every day after school watching
TRL oh my God can you give us a song
from choir yeah no give us one do you
must remember one one year we did like
TV theme songs and that was fun come and
knock on our
[Music]
door wasn't
that got our dear Suzanne Summers is it
rip Suzanne I have been watching Suzanne
and Allen videos and suzan and Allen
she's so Gorge what you know she passed
away okay well you are someone that
might not notice that you just started
singing you just started singing the
song without a tear in your eye I didn't
know what show cuz to me she was on step
by step that was my show with her were
you a child in the 70s like why do you
do you know watch reruns this is like
your that's what you do give me my stay
home from school so you could
watch I'm horny I'm so a b quick I'm in
a basement you sick put it in you
I'm in a basement
squirt wait we're not I love how we're
just not going to share with Kila wasn't
around for the you did a Ring Pop I
wasn't around I we did have Ring Pops in
the Philippines I will say I'm pretty
excited can you guys explain to me what
these why they were special to you cuz I
some of these I didn't experience
dunkaroo is like what she's so lame I'm
becoming autistic I'm sorry I'm going
back to my the age this was around the
time when I was doing my occupational
therapy
[Laughter]
get excited to want to squeeze things
okay explain dunker wait you're excited
for bubble tape Hubba Bubba Bubble tape
why oh we had bubble tape bubble tape
exciting and I have Dunkman and you're
shaking over a bubble tape I'm I'm going
to Bubble tape you to the couch I it
would get so turned on okay dunkaroos
are special because they were like
everywhere in the '90s for childhood and
then one day they just disappeared and
no one could get them and it was really
confusing what are they though but now
they're back it's the concept is [__]
beautiful it's okay these are like the
rebooted version and they're not as good
but oh weren't didn't they used to be
sticks it used to be
little whatever is it it's just little
cookies and then you dip it in [__]
frosting a cup of frosting oh dude we
have Asian Asian people have yanan
that's it's way better I just ate the
frosting that's oh really yeah you had
to try to ration
theal but then I would just go hand at
the end I have to take out my nicotine
po gel what I'm trying to find something
bad and I was i v you don't smoke I know
I just want something bad do you
understand do you understand understand
Annie and I tried vaping and it it made
me tired and upset and it's not for me
it's bad guys it's actually bad I've
decided okay those are great I love how
this is just a stick of pure sugar and
then powder pure sugar do you know what
reminds me of remember the when Apple TV
first came out and you would it had the
from of all time I was why are they the
same size you were dipping it in cand I
I mean if I could have found it I would
I lost it within 10 seconds of that
thing it was before you could be like
voice command just no TV TV was just on
until we unplugged it okay but also the
streaming remote trying to watch a
streaming service on a TV why do you
still have to type in like you know what
I'm saying like there there should be a
keyboard on all voice
command Dave why why are you still tying
Dave should be typing Dave is typing and
putting in pulling up the key that's in
Todd's 90% is plugging in things and
filling things out wow that's in oh what
do you mean is n you know how he does
90% of everything I do 10% it turns out
everything's in his wiping my own ass is
in my 10% that's it everything else Todd
has to I'm actually shocked that that's
what that he would do it he would do it
now we have the bedet he turns it on for
me um this reminds me okay you know what
my other favorite category of snack from
childhood is like the snacks that you
get at the pool at the community pool
the tombstone Pizza that you pay $20 for
but it's worth $3 the grocery store did
you hang out at the pool a lot cuz I was
there kind of surprisingly a little bit
yeah I'm actually offended I was not
kidnapped we were very cute we looked
like the three Hansen Brothers just
walking to the pool and walking home
every night Annie I sent you a link of
the Hansen Brothers now I list listen
they're in my algorithm mine
too not mine they're looking cute guys
there's a little bit of a pudgy belly
I'm going I'm going Taylor come on were
you Taylor everyone thought you were
Taylor yeah I was Taylor thank God yeah
Taylor is Zach was when I was like
they're like you need to lose a little
weight Isaac it's like uh you need to
gain weight cuz your head's very skinny
oh that's right what's that one Baby
Bottle Pop I I always got these These
are so [__] up it's like okay it
reminds me my mom's nipple and it's just
pure sugar like powder thanks Obama yeah
it's just it's just you suck I like how
you were e this was when you were in
your late
20s it was in the Obama Administration I
got really into
these
Michelle um this okay so nerds are not
like the taste I want I I'm I never was
like interested in the taste but the way
that they had the Dual sides the
packaging it was really everything I
love nerds Annie I have one for you to
get really excited about all right put
it in more gum well listen this is this
could that is good go away forever but
the the watermelon Bubble Yum no or
Bubblicious oh Bubblicious watermelon
the Bubble Yum wasn't as good but the
the watermelon Bubblicious was like me
and my neighbor would like make out on a
hammock and chew the gum the flavor
lasted like 5 Seconds yeah but but then
you just chewed more and more and more
you drink this black Kool-Aid for me
wait those aren't meant to be frozen
great no this is a great purple did you
ever put the Caps into your mouth as a
retainer
yes yes I did I used aluminum foil and
pretended that I before I had braces
yeah I did that with um paper clips how
I would stretch out the paper clip and
put it in here oh that makes actually
that looks better fine it was worth it
gtis too braces mistake I really made is
I got those clear braces but they were
you didn't get the
credit what of having being a cool kid
with braces well no but also they're not
clear and they're yellow you had brace
yeah they I didn't we my retainers how
old were you I think I had them like
fifth sixth and seventh grade cuz
they're straight they were really my
teeth were really bad you're not going
to believe this but I had braces for
years I love your your teeth are like my
favorite next your big giant shoulders
that make me feel more comfortable being
next to you I thought that sentence
would end but I love your your teeth are
like I think the IDE like people should
be trying to get a little tiny Gap it's
so cute I got braces too young and my
jaws were not done growing apparently so
when I got them removed they started to
space out again so I'm spacing out
looking into them did you have braces
could you guys in trailer park I had
where I know you secretly grew up no you
know I actually just grew up in a nice
neighborhood I just i' I hitchhiked to
the trailer park I just I identified
this which one is that AirHeads no my
mom oh this is Fruit by the Foot oh I
remember it would have sayings in it it
would have like you've got an arm on you
and Tattoos oh mhm yeah it had
tattoos you didn't have these we didn't
have I okay we might have had them I
just didn't look and it's not to say
that we didn't have exceptional snacks
growing up because we did and Asia is
definitely ahead of the curve when it
comes to Candy I believe that um I just
um yeah these seem like not that fun I
feel like you'd get a Fruit by the Foot
in your
lunchbox so it was like candy wait it
was like healthy candy or I just
remembered okay no then they started
coming out with the like fruit leather
and your parents started to kind of
trick you the
organic this is not by the way my
parents never once tried to trick me in
eating something healthy there was no
thought put into my wellbeing well maybe
they were trying to get you a couple
inches were you allowed to drink soda
there was no rules in my house what part
of you guys think there was rules no I
call it soda okay really were you
allowed no were you not no no we were
let no no no no no no wait I'm so sorry
my parents have Eating Disorders so we
didn't have we would sometimes have food
in the house and sometimes not when I
was little I thought that you were
supposed to drink syrup because my dad
would be chugging anima I come down I
literally thought you would order like a
cup of it my dad would chug it out of
the bottle every morning and then we
used to put it we would have like
Cheerios and we would put the syrup in
the did you ever do that in the cereal
no yes it was so that actually sounds
really good I was so deprived I think my
my parents restricted all of the fun
stuff they needed you to yeah because
they needed me to like be their race
horse basically but what I would do is I
would do you know what Milo powdered
milk is like chocolate powdered milk
yeah I would just eat it from the can
like Scoops into my mouth I would eat
whole sticks of butter just like munch
on the whole stick of butter I would eat
just cane sugar I have a moment to bully
you I have to take oh finally she has a
ring eser oh you guys she finally got
one thank you Annie thanks for
noticing oh my God you're right I'm the
only one unengaged but
like look at it's we're not exactly like
you you don't want to be us my boyriend
graduated from college
okay my fance is has 30 reptiles and my
fiance is has sleep apnea and is not
he's really old wait I'm dating a sleep
apnea boy does he have a seap yeah he
has a CPAP and I find it so cute wait
someone just asked me on my Instagram
DMS what's your advice for making she
just started dating a guy with a CPAP
and asked like how can I make him feel
feel comfortable how would you answer
that um the first night that he spent
the first night he spent over I was like
hey don't forget your seap I want you to
be oxygenated and not wake up with a
headache and I don't know like that's it
I'm like please don't forget your CPAP
da that was really smart because Dave
slept over once early in our
relationship without his CPAP and that
will be the last time that I ever sleep
near it is so brutal it's just all night
it is so so like embarrassing when you
like I used to wear mouth guard like it
is so embarrassing wait does Todd snore
Todd does snore
loudly yeah not too bad I probably snore
more than them the CPAP has so become
like a not embarrassed like I think it's
hot when men do embarrassing things and
they're not embarrassed it's so hot yeah
like if he was just like like hiding it
just wearing the covers over yeah and
also like I love when guys are guys like
when guys are just kind of a little bit
stupid a little bit gross like there's a
little bit of that that I realized
lately like
oh that's good I like that I feel like
these were not
around I like remember when these I
agree with that one I feel like I was
like excited about these and into them
but I remember being grown but I did
like the regular remember life saers
came like CS y little Esther when did
Cream Saver
disappear I don't know exactly cuz with
these things it's always like you wake
up one day and you're like I haven't had
a cream Savers in four years and I don't
know what happened but that was similar
to dunkaroos where it disappeared and
then it literally just came back after I
made a 12-part Instagram series who
could say the correlation did they ever
pay you no what happened was uh there's
this company that's called iconic candy
they've reached out not with any
Financial um benefit to me but they they
bought the cream s like they buy old
things that and then they remake them so
I'm like does that count does it count
if it's not made in the original Factory
by the original corporate overlords
corpses I say the corpses the people
that died making them I don't trust it I
once this was like my most G thing I
ever did for a boyfriend for his
birthday we had had this bit it was like
I started dating this guy around
Halloween and there was this like gummy
ear candy and we would just like
jokingly like put it in each other's
like Pockets like we were always like
kind of like sneaking it back to the
other person what age was this I was 25
he was probably
34 okay it was cute he was my improv
teacher we did bits okay okay okay but
but like honestly the fact that you got
the teacher very impressive I only I got
him third third uh third class I only
got the cross matat not good I followed
on Facebook there was a DM there was a
DM ongoing DMS all night we had a bit
where we would like it was like that's
so funny to date your improv teacher and
then it's everything's bits everything
we would write back to each other would
be like an alphabet it would be like
start with an a then he would do a b
then a c and then we were always like
what city was this in this was in New
York and what what was the age
difference 10 years would I know this
impr teacher maybe what's his name we
can bleep it
out I don't know he um he's he's good
he's a good one I always had a crush on
my improv teacher well he was mean so I
was like really into him he was like a
mean strict teacher I was like sopping
wet I'm
like and to yell at someone in an improv
class is so funny I always had a crush
on you're not Zip Zap zapping enough
improv teachers are improv coaches and
then always had someone put a fer out
and it was just it was never it never
they probably all had a crush on you
they didn't if they did that they didn't
if they did they didn't
no The Improv teachers were always like
getting hot chit like it was always like
you it was some of my improv teachers
ended up with like girls where I'm like
this is
crazy this is crazy but so we had this
bit where we would like for like months
we were just like every time one of us
would like leave we would like slide
this candy and each other's things so um
so I found the manufacturer that made
the and then I got him like a box of
them so he like unwrapped and he I'll
tell you it was an annoying bit because
then he was just left with all this
candy and I was like bye he at your
house not mine that's so sweet I feel
like you really are like a very
thoughtful gift Giver that's your
strength sometimes I'll forget to give a
gift completely and then you'll get a
weird one in March I'm not really a good
Gift Giver Giver in general or I'm not
also not I'm a really bad gift receiver
no I like do you know what I like what
well because when I do get you something
I am trying to get you something you're
going to use cuz I feel like that's the
only way to into your heart is like save
you a dollar I ha every gift I get I I'm
like I can't hide it like if someone
gives me a gift and I don't like it my I
my instinct just be like why did you get
me this well say out loud to them kind
of sometimes I call it Christmas face I
don't have Christmas face like yeah what
is has Dave bombed with a couple gifts
this is not a safe subject he stopped
buying me gifts like8 years ago because
there was our first Valentine's Day was
really bad what did he get
you this is safe he got me edible
underwear can you imagine a
mug now in his defense he'd be like oh
was a specialty mug for tea and you had
been drinking tea what did it say on it
it didn't say anything on it Annie and
honestly Yik when you open a Valentine's
Day gift from your new boyfriend you
didn't even shove like a thong in there
and you've been together like seven
months
and it's a mug I'm like okay like did
you just are we co-workers now it is
actually thoughtful though because he
was watching your patterns and the
things you were doing what would you
have wanted I that's the thing I don't
know I can't you can't win what if he
got you one of those mugs that's like
the handle is a penis and it's balls St
but what would you have done cuz I
obviously think that was perfect what
what if he had shown up with you know
like the Undertaker the wrestler would
just eser across his neck tattoo okay
that would that would Tri
but I also and I know that it makes you
sound like a brat it's just like don't
get me gifts like I everyone in my life
I'm like no gifts please like I can't
handle it and where do you think that
comes from did you grow up um receiving
gifts or for well not not Christmas
obviously no we did Christmas I think I
know what it is what I think when you
get a gift that's not something that you
really want it feels like people and it
also feels like people don't like know
you're like well I just feel bad I'm
like you wasted money and like we need
to fix this we need to return this like
and then one other time he tried I feel
so bad like cuz it was when I was
hosting glowing up which was like a
podcast about skincare and he got me
this huge box of like all this really
nice Korean skincare and I'm like you're
like I get it free no but I was I was
like Dave like Korean skincare breaks me
out
like I can't wa what is what is the best
gift you've ever received from anyone
where you were like oh they nailed this
I mean what comes to mind first is um my
16th birthday like my dad got a car no
yeah are you
kidding are you [__] kidding like
they came out there was just a bow on a
car what the neighbors they took me to
we went to Mangano's classiest joint in
the city in skoki and I my dad like gave
me a gift and it was a Fanny May box
which is like a famous you know Chicago
chocolate here and it was here's why it
was good because there was a
misdirection because as soon as they
handed me The Fanny May Box I was like
are you [__] kid kidding me I was in
a [__] mood and then I opened it and
there was like a trip ticket for to to
taking me to New York oh so you like to
be gifted experiences I think so or just
like something like when you went to
Japan well that wasn't a gift was a
nightmare those a Paralympics do you
guys have like a best gift that you've
ever had do you remember I like giving
gifts more than receiving them I like
getting gifts too though um I like
giving giving is fun for me giving is
fun actually when you when you really
nail it and when you really like that's
fun I like when people know I'm paying
attention and I know like I think I did
a good swing for you but it didn't work
when I got you the gold tongue scraper
oh but it was too thick yeah it hurt it
actually hurt me but that is like a win
for me that's a pretty that's really
good actually that is really the thought
is there got like a like an up level of
a thing I know you use goldplated tongue
scraper is pretty cool I once gave my um
my uh third grade girlfriend my mom's
Pearls by so was she pissed yeah my mom
was pissed and the the girl's mom
actually had to return him and then the
Lord uh punished All of You by making
you only want PE necklaces given by men
the rest of your life that's that's what
made me
gay you were so bad at being straight
mhm did you or Bobby ever have like a
big fun like gift giving or receiving no
he's
a uh let me guys see just threw cash you
was like Buy Herself a gift like gift
cards yeah like I think our first gift
cards are actually so funny my first
birthday it was like a gas card
Starbucks and then Target each one was
worth $100 and he just like slid it
across the table I like it honestly I
love that yeah yeah I was like oh thanks
practical I for my first gift to him
because we were obsessed with my 600
pound life so yeah that's what turned
you you guys got horny yeah we got horny
did you like the whale I I it was it was
a hard watch for me on the plane cuz I
watched it on an international flight
and I was like I think I'm going to get
a panic attack just listening to the
breathing was a lot why would they do
that to us I know that was that was I've
spent my whole life not ever being in
that situation in what situation
seeing a obese maner off really struggle
the opening scene is just him dying from
jerking
yeah but I I so I our first Christmas
together I framed it was a framed
picture of our favorite um contestants
contestants people on my 600 PB life and
I made it into a Christmas card and I
framed it he thought it was really funny
but then he didn't really that's that's
it I made my ex-boyfriend he like loved
my ass so I made him a birthday card
once that was like the front was like my
ass with a skirt on and then you lifted
it and said happy birthday and it was
like my skirt came up oh my God what do
you think about people who do like full
like budoir sessions and make calendars
for their Partners I think anytime a
gift is a photo of yourself it's like
not a gift it's it's funny though I've
had it do this to me but a budoir thing
is like to me like a little cheesy it's
a little like red shoe can I tell you
what this guy did to me aside from
obviously I've told you like he bought
himself a plain ticket to join my family
vacation that he was not invited to but
he made me an alum
it was like on the on the last page it
was like all pictures of him but the
last page it was of him in one of those
like Thrones you know those like uh
furniture that looks that looks like a
throne and it said in the bottom a a
king is not a king without his Queen but
it's just a picture of him and like I
was 22 I didn't know any better he was
40 so I Dr Remy or
what Romy we need you yeah and I that's
so disgusting I don't know I stayed with
them for like a year and a half but I
did but I now I look back and I'm like
why didn't someone intervene when they
saw this [__] like who were the
adults in my life this is why creepy
guys have to date women in their 20s cuz
they're stupid like you were too stupid
to know
better no no yes of course well you're
just in it's when you're young it's just
hard to get out of relationships too for
some reason and you don't know what's
right and what's wrong kind of you know
what I do need to give Dave credit cuz
there was one funny gift he really
nailed which is then and I'm revealing
something very embarrassing about myself
but when I was like probably this was
like eight years ago I would jokingly
often refer to myself to Dave as a
skinny pretty famous humble
comedian and he got me like for one
Whatever holiday it was like this like
like you know underwear that said that
on the back and like a bunch of stuff
that said that and that was pretty funny
my my best friend um in high school or
like a little bit after high
school my 18th birthday everyone kind of
wasn't there like she had a she was on a
trip my parents were out of time like it
was like this weird like I guess we're
doing this alone as a twin you know like
doing things alone um but so she knew
she was G to be out of town so she like
left outside my door it was a DVD of
Adventures and babysitting and then she
like made her like she put like her face
on like a cup and like like an upside
down cup and it was like really cute
then she friend D me two years later but
it was a really good it was a great it
was a cute you should get one of those
shirts that says dump her dump her dump
me was it a formal I'm with dump just
dump me was it a formal dumping do
people do that where they have a sit
down talk friend dumping I wasn't taking
The Dumping I was just like thought she
was busy cuz I was like we loved each
other and she had like written me this
when when I went off to college she
wrote me this like letter about like
that was I felt so seen by her like
about how cool I just like this whole
like really she's like I feel like I'm
giving a eulogy it was just this really
sweet little notebook paper she's like
don't read this until you leave or
whatever that's already sounds too
intense she in love with you
no I think what happened
was I'm just I am obviously like a lot
and I am always
like myself whether I'm trying to be or
not
and she got into this like really
hipster crowd when she she ended up
going to um School in Michigan and she
got into this like really hipster like
art crew where you can't like I was like
a liability I feel like with them where
I was just going to come in and be like
cuz I just called people like I would
just be like okay no we went out for New
Year's we were in New York and and her
friends were being like they were like
being condescending to me and I'm like
not I I'm I think I'm pretty like aware
of when that's happening or whatever so
I would just kind of like let role and
then I kind of would just call it out
and um and she sided with she was like
Annie you're giving us all headaches or
something and I was like she like you're
like I know I was like yeah and the more
you ignore me the crazier I feel the
more I'm going to talk don't you know
I'm like a pull talk toy [__] like I
there was like trouble in Paradise but I
just I don't know I always thought it
was just like she was going through
stuff and then I think she just had a
boyfriend who I mean my interpretation
was I obviously I don't know what was
going I'm like old enough to know that
like but he he was treating her in a way
that I didn't like seeing him treat her
be treated but I don't know what had
been going on just I just felt like he
was being rude and I would kind of like
try to make a joke about it and then
that wasn't cool and then I ended up
running into her years later on the
subway New York and she was like yeah I
married that guy and was say any with
their names but she's like I married him
like and I was like that's great like I
don't know she it just seemed like she
was like I don't know thought that that
I was didn't The One That Got
Away it's all the story sounds like a
lesbian movie If I I did take her I did
take her with me to go hang out with my
um my friends everyone fell in love with
her like she was like very very
beautiful very funny very cool she's
still I mean I haven't seen her in years
but I'm sure she still is but uh really
just like a funny smart person and um I
brought her I had these friends that I
met through my like Quaker stuff that
lived up in Williamsport and I would go
up and hang out with them and we do like
country things like go snow mobiles and
go caving and spelunking and [__] and
weird stuff but um I remember bringing
her to one of those parties and she they
obviously were immediately in love with
her and I just had to be like this is
what happens here she is here she is and
um and it ended up with all of us like
on mushrooms and she definitely was
masturbating in front of everyone in a
bed like we were like people were
starting to make out but she was just
fully M there were some interesting H
that never happened public is crazy I've
never just started masturbating in front
of a group but I remember being like oh
okay well my friends were like your
friend's
awesome there is a category of gifts
though that actually I do appreciate and
I think is good and you can't really
[__] up which is a surprise gift like
it's not a birthday it's not a holiday
it's just like a random gift because I
remember and I I feel like I need to
give Dave credit cuz all I do is talk
[__] about him on this podcast you
really do not he's like whenever he
listens he's like well I heard you know
it's just something like bad I said
about I like you don't you're not
attracted to me whatever
um that's my sorry we just made you say
it again actually that's why I stand up
like go through the the thing he gets
mad about can you tell us more um but
when we first started dating and I did a
I had a podcast called weird adults and
I had just recorded an episode with
Eliza slesinger where we like went into
like basic girl stuff and talked all
about Yankee Candles and I know and we
had been da me and Dave had been like 3
weeks in and literally I go to his
apartment and he bought all these Yankee
Candles for me and I was
like how many was it just a
manora it was probably like four or five
but I'm like no one has it was sweet so
sweetful he listened to the episode yes
okay like that was like guys if you're
listening like well 3 to five weeks be
careful guys don't listen and you know
don't be too that that was like oh we
I'm marrying you no matter what what was
the smell what was the scent do you
remember what the scent was no I don't
remember all prob cookies and stuff Yes
actually like frosting my dad got me I
really wanted I was like getting
obsessed with uog like I just loved like
what I don't know I just love the idea I
like I never knew they were called uog
what is a uog the scene of a
fireplace that just plays I couldn't I
don't know why I was like I was like oh
that is that's cool I was like they're
called Ula and then I was like I love
ulog they're awesome and I I get this
like this present and it says dreams
come true and I opened it was like yog a
but what do you mean like a figurines it
was like a it was like a DVD of like a
fireplace oh ulog is also a very
delicious cake yes
correct my butter icing what do you guys
say when you get a gift that you don't
like like what's your face or your what
do you say in terms of like your
reaction get this I've
why would you get me this you're up
front like that about it do you have a
receipt my friend did get me something
so I'm trying to like declutter so
sometimes when people give me things I'm
like this is insane if you think I'm not
throwing this out but
like yeah she got me a decorative like
thing
for I'm not decorating my house
lady okay not doing holiday decorations
all right so you tell them right up
front then
why did you get this it's family or you
know Dave after this long but he does
like I said he doesn't really get me
anything was it you because I remember
which I thought was actually a really
great gift for you I remember having to
run around to three different places
with Jenna to find um an arow on um
sweatshirt and sweatpants wait but that
wasn't even from her that was from
Caroline I got that well I went with her
to go pick it up I wasn't sure who it
was for I wonder if was for me was it
yeah we went to some place close to
Hamburger Marys to pick it up oh wow
wait that's so crazy that you were
involved in
that yeah so I was like oh this is
actually a really clever gift and
another thing I thought it was like oh
Esther would probably like like the
Costco Kirkland sweatshirts I just saw
that on Tik Tok and was like I really
want this they're sold out sold out I
did get a Wawa hoodie like immediately
when I knew they existed I have like
them in every colors and I'm like I'm a
I got to get it's such a good idea like
like 7eleven hoodie Zippy give me that
like that's we don't sell it to me at
Target I don't like when that happen you
know when Target will be like oh selling
it's like Sriracha shirt it pisses me
off I'm not into but the 7-Eleven did a
collab with Crocs right mhm that was a
good one it was a little bit of an
insane clog but you know yeah super
cute um how do we feel about Britney
these days guys do we feel as though was
a right decision to free her completely
I love her so much and I like I don't
know the situation I don't know how to
solve it I don't know how to fix it I'm
not going to pretend like like one
answer is right and one is wrong she's
unwell I mean I think we can say that
she's unwell I think maybe we're afraid
of Britney people coming after us but
she's unwell I mean this is unwell girl
she's swinging around Britney people not
see that she's unwell or did they very
unwell and I don't know what was going
on in that conserva trip maybe that was
very bad I don't know but this is this
person is in danger but did you see the
news that came out today about her
Memoir about the
abortion I did see that she obviously
Everyone Knows by now if you know then
everyone knows but because I know you're
not on Tik Tok or you are but I'm
looking at lipos suction and nostrils
cuz not my level um so yes she came out
and said that Justin sort of like nudged
her he got her pregnant and he's going
to be so nudged her towards the abortion
and she 's a very religious girl and I
think like it's clear that that has had
some sort of really deep in profound
negative impact on her and then when you
go back and watch the Every Time music
video and there's a woman giving birth
and the lyrics are like every time I try
to fly I fall with like I don't know
there's just the baby falls out of me it
feels really sad and like this could
have [__] up her whole life as in a as
in a
bobo experience as yeah as an
experienced abortionist what's your
abortion I
mean abortion no abolitionist
abolitionist yeah as a baby abolitionist
yes well I can answer your question like
can you see how that could affect her
like are you IMU are you immune to
having like a negative impact of that
when I was 19 was my first abortion and
um it was rough but I felt like it was
the right thing to do and there was
relief at the end of it it wasn't
physically rough it was rough for me why
um I don't know but I remember like just
being just having to diaper for yeah
just not well yeah I think I was like
over sedated I don't know what it was
but um no it was like not a great time
but also like I felt like relief because
it's what I wanted to do right yeah
that's different right so I don't know
what the pressures in her young career
were you know what maybe even more than
just Justin I'm sure other people in her
life were probably like you cannot be
pregnant now um so I can't imagine that
you know being easy I mean also like I
have seen the clips of every time she's
being interviewed by anyone they're like
talking about her tits and stuff and it
is like she was just like a Christian
girl and they're like it's not like she
picked those outfits out remember the
Rolling Stone but yeah but still you can
be a baby [__] and not want to yeah also
you're allowed to dress [__] and not
have people will be like tell us about
your tits well just like what what do
you want to hear yeah no it's very
[__] up and I I'm definitely ordering
the book and I like it even though I
when you do see some of the social posts
you're like I don't understand how she
wrote a book
but I'm going to get listen a lot of
people have written books okay come on
now there's a lot of books out there by
people are you guys gonna read Julia
Fox's
book um yes I ordered it maybe we can
maybe now it's time to get her on no she
was on yeah we can that's doable she's
had a crazy
life we want her we'll do a denim
episode Julia Fox will you be on our
show not that we haven't asked you a
million times already yeah I mean when
you say read I mean I'll probably maybe
an audio audio book yeah I don't
reading's hard do you think it was the
right thing to do that she did have the
abortion I that's only something she can
answer are you asking her as a nurse
yeah yeah like it's so but for pop music
is was the right move I mean for your
sake yes she was 19 was she yeah yeah 19
okay yeah that would have been shock
probably a lot of us would already have
kids that's what I was just thinking
yeah we would all have gotten coped her
for
sure that could would have been a star
though is it [__] up to say that maybe
she has kids yeah but if her and J had a
kid F line come on does that really
count dancer yeah but it's JT I don't I
know how he gained so much
weight he was so hot he mov to e e I
know but come on E but come on you know
me that's my
thing it's the hot it was so hot oh my
God that's crazy Annie no one thinks
that he was so hot but if you if you
take away what he is but he was so hot
that was my type yes I see it I see ity
wasn't his type okay you know what I
mean well he had a you know Char Jackson
was pregnant yes I'm not saying I liked
his personality or wanted to date him or
had a crush on him I'm just saying he
was hot oh that's right Scott Peters I
don't appreciate what he did I also
think Scott Peterson was hot smoking hot
Scott Peterson he killed his wife he has
that just thick daddy look yeah
yeah I like so speaking of that we have
a little game that we want to play with
you
guys um it's a little
trivia fast question game with a prize
at the end we have a little butt priz
something Esther won't like honestly I
think Esther might actually love the
prize yes I just realized that every
party I went to when I was like 18 19
like adult parties that I would go to
when I got invited to them finally I
would
bring lollipops cuz I thought it was
cute and I'm realizing how disgusting
that is why is that disgusting because I
was young and it was
like yeah yeah you should be the same
age as every fig but we were all on
Molly so our ecstasy was called right so
we have this little button sorry that I
stopped you like while you were bringing
in a heavy guys this is
amazing holy [__] this is incredible I
like these pants too oh my God cute we
have a
Podium we have a little Podium so you
what we're going to do is ask you the
questions and if you know the answer you
have to get up and Buzz it as fast as
you can we're going to keep kind of
question I'm worried about these are
related
question I'm going to lose
this if it's 2000 y 2K question yeah y
2K question Sor Jordan and then whoever
has the most points at the end gets a
trophy gets a little a gift fun GI that
we're excited about okay okay so are you
guys ready you guys
ready okay question question
one what four artists sing in Lady
Marmalade oh
K Maya Pink Christina
agilera and oh my God who's the fourth
one hang on how many seconds do I have
you got five seconds five five 4 3 2
1 is
it is it Missy Elliot no no you're L
wasn't it
what did you say it wasn't Lil Kim it
was it was you bought
it it was Lil Kim I would never have
gotten Maya I forgot about that [__] oh
my God got three of four who wins that
but bonus I think you all get I forgot
about my ghet Superstar uh there is a
bonus to that who intros the video oh
it's Missy Elliot yeah okay so I wasn't
totally okay did I ever tell you about
when my friend Abby and I went to a miss
concert and we blew up trash bags with
air like we had to blow into them to be
like that thing and no and it was so hot
and so disgusting and it was so
uncomfortable to get through the crowd
and no one thought it was cool or like
it sounds like you had a really fun life
no I'm what I'm telling you is I'm very
me and my friends are very creative that
is so funny that's so but we were like
this is going to [__] kill and nobody
cared we were laughing so hard oh my God
if I can find a picture you can next
question okay next
question who is is look at this I know I
don't like playing with you at all I
don't like playing with you at all who
is alien Gonzalez Elon Gonzalez oh the
he grew up hot
who oh he was the kid that um was being
torn between Cuba and Florida with the
parents and Grand yeah all that yeah did
grow up he grew up he grew up he got I
mean I I hope he grew up he he ended up
studying engineering and he's now like
like he's going to run for government in
Cuba it's actually but bonus question
who championed him in the
US H was it Janet Reno a celebrity a
celebrity it was his big
Champion oh wait Gloria Stefan yes Jesus
I do not like playing with you you're
like Dave you win you guys are friends
why are you you are should be used to
this you're shorter than everyone I know
but I like this subject and I thought I
had a chance
but you're not doing great I know that
look at her she's not even no no no no
no she's not even from this country and
she no Ester you need to get with
yourself and she's just slapping the
thing first you would have gotten Gloria
ston what what states did the girls in
simple life travel
to how many are there we might as well
guess we might as well
guess great Annie Alabama
Arkansas
um this degree of difficulty was too
hard West
Virginia um good job that was all of
them yeah that was Julian's question
yeah did I really get all of them right
you didn't get all oh is are there more
Texas there's Idaho yeah right up there
this is just Idaho Florida Vermont Texas
South Carolina New York this is this a
crazy question okay that so we're going
to we're going to get rid of it and we
have a life on DVD and I don't know that
okay next question a DVD player yeah
what movie did Lindsay Lohan star in
2005 2005 o Esther Mean Girls nope
Confessions of a Teenage Drama Queen how
many guesses did she get one guess one
guess okay 2005 was she was that was
2005 was it Freaky Friday
nope um kby fully loaded yes
kby that's just like I haven't seen any
movies was mean girls4 huh was Mean
Girls 2004 yes Mean Girls was 2004 that
was a hard one I would have never gotten
that I didn't it just was I didn't even
it was just in my brain too I didn't
even think it just came out you just had
that low hand Herby fully loaded in
there waiting to come out see you are
like a kind of like a little car tiny
little car
next question please name all of the
back street boys members as well as in
sync back stre boys
Kevin um Kevin nick uh
AJ and oh my God what's that little
guy's
name the blonde one is it Brian Brian
yeah thanks for the assist don't have
her though um is there another one no
that's it I can do insane insinc is
Chris Patrick the hot one um Joy phon
the hot one uh the other hot one the
Hideous nerd Justin Timberlake and uh JC
you're missing one and um
gay she needed a point she need a point
to leave the gay you can't leave gay
homophobic number relation to I feel
like he's or in us at all times really
is he a comedy fan or comedy person he's
just like friends with Justin Martell
and he's okay on mhm I love it next
question what food C wait I have a
question does this look like my body
this Podium why did you make a Podium
shaped exactly like my
body w why am I having the most fun I've
ever had in my life we need games every
week yeah great okay number six what
food court restaurant had an Italian
flag in the logo oh God
borrow wait guys can we just talk about
food cords for one second I need to just
think about it master walk mhm your L if
you're
watching I didn't mean to H if your
lowain why did you I love you thank you
sesame chicken oh when they gave me that
my first ever sesame chicken sample they
don't know they didn't know what they
were doing my dad and I we go Mall
walking and we go through and we do the
rounds and we see how many we can
collect how many two pck what's the
place called I think it was master walk
master was my
[__]
egg Subway give me a Subway the only
reason that I knew Sparro was because it
was a huge deal when it came to my city
in the Philippines and there was like a
long line around and it was that's the
only reason why w r the the bread sticks
were also and then there was always like
a gyro place and then there was like oh
God that food course orang smoothie spot
yeah
DQ why I want a food court right now we
have a food court in oh we can have a
food court episode that's a great idea
just wear the merch yeah can I tell you
though I'm really sad that like Panda
Express kind of took out master walk
were they in competition Panda it's just
panda is more popular to master walk was
better master I do love a good Panda
sesh though I never really got found my
footing with panda Maybe you should take
me and show me around one time I did a
show near Panda Express and then
afterwards I I had a good set so
afterwards I had to celebrate but Bing
eating and I saw these guys like from
the show and they were like oh good job
or whatever right and so then I go I'm
like oh I'm like I take a [__] so bad I
was like [__] so I go and I'm like
taking this [__] I'm like how am I going
to like explain away why I've been in
here so long uh cuz I figured obviously
I want to stay get my autograph picture
whatever they were completely gone when
I came out like they were not still
there I thought they'd be like like it
was like Good Morning America and they
had like signs up
front next next
question
what is one political conflict of the
early 2000s not including
911 political conflict I'm out um of the
2000s yeah early 2000 there's no way
you're going to get this of the early
2000s uh there's always been not peace
in the Middle East I could say that um
I okay sorry Clinton was a little early
for that I got a couple okay okay the
weapons of mass destruction MH obviously
that's kind of 9111 a little 9 about um
Gore versus Bush and um The Electoral
count that's pretty good that was pretty
good was that before that's on the list
you got it that was it right was that
before 2000 oh yeah
yeah kind of close that was pretty good
silver a funny joke she's like I don't
have kids so I don't have anything to
like show time except like 911 is like
our only time marker that's really
funny what was the top grossing movie of
2002 Titanic was 99 uh was it Romeo
Juliet 90s
yeah oh I like this this feels like Doug
Benson's what the [__] can we get a clue
yeah
[Music]
um let's say do you want me to say the
star
super okay was it
Armageddon no that's in the
90s wait super super bad
superhero oh um Spider-Man
yeah oh it's so boring the Toby McGuire
Spider-Mans were so good they were so
good Spiderman 2 Doc O that was a good
one too
yes get a grip who
hosted the TV
show shot at
love wait hosted wait was it Tila
Tequila the
host who recently became very cancelled
wait the shot at love was hosted by her
yeah she's the the main no she wouldn't
be the host would she I guess they did
host their own shows I think she did
host it they did host
tequila but what was the the Brett
Michaels one was it what was it called
Rock of Love R yeah trying to get me out
on the point I know wow that was
actually a show I watched with atila
tequila because that was the first one
where she was dating guys and girls oh
that's cool guys when I went on um when
I went on Breakfast Club I was wearing a
cowboy hat I was like in a cowboy hat
day pH and everyone said I looked like
all the comments said I looked like I
was in Rock of Love yeah what's her name
like a year ago oh great VH1 what a what
a source of Joy TR was so fun it was so
fun to have that place I know and it was
cute remember Carson da like was friends
with Britney and yeah that was my did
you Carson and he was dating terara Reed
right yeah he was dating Tera Reed yeah
I remember he dated Britney for a second
didn't he I don't think so yes I think
so no he
didon Carson daily dated like a lot of
people a I remember he had black
fingernails yeah when it wasn't you know
who he's married to who Dave King's
former assistant really
yes Dave worked on the last call Carson
da like the old
iteration he dated Tara Reed yes Tara
Reed I do remember that yeah do we have
one more
okay couple more what's the score Julian
the score o i mean Annie you're you're
in last place with one point um we got
four for Kila and has three I meditate
my ego is not attou can I just say thank
you I've never not been in last place if
this was a gift for me well I think it's
like everybody knows that you're like a
last paac person so I can okay these are
these two are going to be lightning
round natur winner lightning round these
two are going to be just like two quick
shot fires okay you
ready Britney or Christina there is a
right answer who's better got to get the
better I'm saying Christina I don't care
sorry you're I'm saying Christina I'm
saying it I don't care yeah but that is
that's fair but wrong answer her voice
is better correct she's a better voice
we all know that not about that is it
about sanity
it's are we asking who's the better
mother I think
Christina it is true this yours that is
true okay okay next this is a similar
similar question Mandy or
Jessica oh well that's a hard one um
these are so subjective yeah exactly
these are really subjective but for the
2000s I'm going to say it was Jessica
yeah Mandy had nothing had now maybe but
the 2000s were ra Jessica look of course
Mandy has like a real Mandy kind of had
better song she did cand do song was
pretty really good I mean and she was in
A Walk to Remember to Remember yeah I
think she was a little too classy to be
it was like you're not supposed to be
here Jessica was like church born into
to it supposed to be yeah she's kind of
the original ktie Perry in a way but
think about yes it's 7:00 on the dot
where's
Usher in the
club Kila go ahead his drop top yes
cruising the
streets great work I loveer I love guys
that's what we should do is we should go
to Usher show we should people say it's
really good yeah I want to see Katy
Perry but okay I would love to see Katy
Perry to I feel like we're supposed to
be friends with Katy Perry sure
sure but you're okay I'm what the loser
so I want to talk to you about
it you somehow will [__] this up go up
too hot okay we have one more and you
can choose to partake in this or not um
two of you we'd like for you to do your
best impression of Sharon and Aussie
Osborne from the Osborne show oh I'm out
of this one well shorty looks like
Azie I always wanted to do his hairstyle
where he has like the maroon red red
underneath I love his hair color um
oie it's pretty
good oh oie shut the [__] up and wipe
your
ass sh yeah remember when then he got
the brain iner afterwards and we were
like and he's he's not bad they started
a podcast and he's with it who a yeah I
think I feel like he played that up or
was he still [__] up
then I don't know oh there's one more
thing for the there is one more in the
buttons okay that's okay okay the
question the tie breaker between Esther
and KLA wait I got the Usher one there's
no way this is she can't you got
it everyone's scared to tell Kila she
might lose just to get beat by my mom if
she sees
this we're pretending it's it's tied
this is like you have to just take the
fall for her so she doesn't get be KLA
and eser say you're the one that so this
is the
question which unexpected candidate was
elected governor in
Arnold for the record I also knew that
yeah I mean I think we all knew that I
not only did I know that I named my blue
tongue skink after him did you really
I oh my God tricks I've never had these
are they good what they're so good I've
never had
them ever like in my life I've had like
fro Loops is that the same it's very
similar but it's different these are
special you know what I forgot about
Sugar Smacks did you guys ever eat
those what are they they're just candy
it's just candy I have a topic I want to
bring up
yes Kila I've had her shirt for six
months now hadra t-shirt for six months
now I cannot
have someone's property it makes me so
uncomfortable I keep wearing it I can't
stop wearing it I can't stop wearing it
every time a picture is posted I'm like
oh my God I got to get her her shirt
pack today was in a pile and a in a bag
of my stuff okay I was like it's dirty I
don't give a [__] I'm bringing it I got
to bring it to her forgot it on the way
over I'm not really weird about um
sharing clothing like I've never been
that person is like where's my stuff
back um I find that people who are not
generous with their things I don't
necessarily have like a deep friendship
with I would just be like okay my
nightmare is you thinking I'm doing it
on purpose and not giving stole your
stuff well I've had one person do this
which I I cannot confront her about
because I feel like I just don't know
how to do it so I was like hey did I
leave my sunglasses at your house and
she was like yes she took a picture of
them and then never gave them to you and
so I knew that they were at her house
those specific ones and then when I saw
her again I was like can I have my
sunglasses and she hands me a really
cheap $20 pair of Costco ones and I was
like oh these aren't it she was like
those are the ones I had no she duped
you she Amazon duped you she duped me
and I was like these aren't it she was
like oh those are the ones we must have
just you know I just assumed those were
it so I said yes I had them and I'm like
she forgot she sent me a
picture so I got I don't know but we're
not that close and I don't know her that
well and I don't know how to confront
her no she's not that's weird so like
how do I even and now it's it's
month so like I'm not I'm not I'm going
to have this
in I just realized too that I lied as a
kid about my name I didn't like telling
people my real name cuz either they they
had a hard time saying it they um but I
used to tell people my name was
Christine for like the first oh my God
what that's such a weird remember years
old so weird if her name was Christine
wait did you not like your name I didn't
like my name I didn't think it suited me
very sexy and adult well um so did
everyone else think that about you so
when I remember being five and telling a
stranger like oh yeah you're so cute
what's your name I'm like Christine and
maybe up until the age of like seven I
used to do that occasionally I didn't
like my name but I never came up with
like a you make sense yours makes sense
I know a wild one hers is I feel like
because no one else had it and it I
could see how as a kid you're like
embarrassed or something and like have
to explain that age and everything in it
yeah I also have a silent h in my name
yeah do I learned so does
Annie honey honey honey wait did you
like your name growing
up um yeah I mean I definitely my name
is
an my on my birth certificate so I
definitely was like I think I got a cool
name compared to that like you don't
like an well an would have just felt
insane I just named um this dog I
rescued in the Philippines Dr legs I I
named her an yeah Anne Curtis who was
like a celebrity back home and she was
like really she had full of mange all
over her body she was one of like [__]
up so I'm like a you could I named her
after like the you know the most famous
prettiest actress in the Philippines
just to counter the fine you can call me
an so yeah Ann is not bad it's not
hitting as you're a
kid you my name is eser you can't have
that with me I yeah no um there was when
I used to play games I always wanted to
be the age 19 like when we were kids
playing 19 29 and my name was
Christina interesting cuz I think those
were the really unpopular names when we
were growing up they felt like
hairdresser names and stuff like pretty
I wanted my name to be Sarah Sarah cuz
all the pretty white girls were named
Sarah and I no one knew how to say
Estella so I was I wanted to be S Asian
babies name Estella Estella is such a
classic beautiful name I think my name I
probably like was like I like names like
Alexis like sexy girl names my
sister-in-law's name is Alexi isn't that
cute that's cute really cute and she's
like hot hairdresser type like she's a
hottie Alexa was really common in the
Philippines and then I know it's such a
nightmare now though yeah worst name to
have that and Karen it's like just
rename yourself still naming their
children uh Pamela or um Stephanie or
like are they still you don't hear those
or like um
Janet you just named all of my so all of
Julian's cousins names that's my aunt
and her daughter aunt is Janet daughter
is Stephanie and then a good friend of
bars is Pam really I mean Pam is such a
cute name Pam is cute in Middle School I
knew this a girl named Janet and she was
so beautiful like she she was from a
different school and but she was like
you know kind of in our friend group she
was really pretty and really cool and I
remember one day we were all like
hanging out
eating and Janet goes us TR to tell you
something and we're all like eating and
she's like I have feelings for this guy
Nick who was my ex and I like and I
remember when she started talking to me
I was pouring ketchup and I was like oh
and then like I poured the whole bottle
out cuz I was like it just blew me away
like this hot girl like my ex was like
such a bad scary feeling I don't know I
just have not heard the name Janet since
the do you know how many uggos I have
raised their street value
on that's your specialty I think it
might have been mine at one point too
like you just bring their you know it's
a cheerleader effect right it's guys
really start to look better maybe we're
all very confident and like have our own
taste so that's why we we're people that
we choose the ugly guys no no what mine
was low
self-esteem that too mine was mean I had
this um one of my exes got just got his
wife just left him I don't care this is
so long ago like I can't give a [__]
about this person but so many of my old
friends are like did you hear what
happened they like want to give me the
gos about it that's how he's bad he's
bad I wish someone would be that for my
ex but is that so funny I wish I had a
did you hear what happened people are
like trying to break the news it's like
when a celebrity dies people like did
you hear I just met a person who has a
phobia of long like cucumber or banana
shaped things like if he sees a whole
banana a guy it's a guy he's like
freaked out or a hot dog he has to see
it sliced up is he straight he's
straight and married and everything
where do you think he's closeted he's
like guys such a strong reaction to a
fall men are not allowed to have phobias
that's you can't have that what okay I
okay so I was watching this documentary
about this Manor where it's like a haunt
it's supposed to be a haunt but it's
this guy basically just tortures people
and he says they can get through it it's
supposed to be like a like a liveaction
horror movie you go into like you to get
scared they're doing I met these guys
that are so awesome they came to my show
in in San Diego but Todd's been obsessed
with them for a long time but in a lot
of these places though they'll interview
you and ask you what your biggest fears
are ahead of time and then they like
make the Haunted House towards your
biggest fears so what would
yours what what would but it's but this
guy just ends up torturing it's like
he's waterboarding it's like a nightmare
what are things that he's
done his isn't like I don't know like if
you're afraid of spiders or something I
just watched a thing on I mean mine
would be like being buried alive
cockroaches for you drowning cockroaches
what are they going to do try to bury
you alive like this is crazy
I mean for the guy that I just talked
about it' just be a room full of
cucumbers and hot dogs and bananas I
think what does it mean
if a guy turns down a nude for
me
what um sorry an and also so I
was you know a couple months ago I was
seeing somebody and you know things were
getting into like the sexual talk Arena
and um over phone and I was about to
send him a
nude and he was like no like no
thanks did he say why no he's just like
I'd rather like find out like I don't
want to be my God he's trying to be
special yeah tell me tell me break it
down for meit did you say just trying to
be cool like let me be different G well
there is the whole thing though on the
dating scene where people are like I
don't want to
see your like Instagram or your online
presence like I want to get to know you
in person like I think that's been a big
movement lately maybe that's like a but
are you really not looking at it are you
looking at it and then going in and
pretending you didn't that's a okay I
believe you like I think you're that's
right this people say what you are what
are you before I go to date with you but
also like I can kind of see from from I
I wouldn't want a nude from him like
that I would how fast were you going to
send it I mean it was such a great
picture of me I've had it you know for a
years now and I was just really like
waiting oh hell yeah do you not recycle
nudes does it have to be you know taken
in that that day well when it's the same
person for 10 years like actually he has
no memory I could totally recycle but I
have a friend that sent her nudes and
then her boyfriend wrote back like notes
on how the picture could have been
better that's disturbing what yeah and
what were the notes well he was a
director so he fancied like he thought
was he just trying to be clever that's
kind of funny though was he being funny
no he was not being funny he was being a
th% serious but like actually talking
about her bits and her Parts well he was
like this the angle this angle I just
say something she's she's an autistic
partner that's an autis that's autism
fairly famous too that has to be who is
it we will bleep it out um his name is
he
directed I don't know if you guys saw
that movie okay he
gave her like a bunch of notes on her
nudes and was like this angle is wrong
and it was the craziest thing for what
is he straight yeah I would be
devastated I know if someone came back
with
notes I know that I've never done online
dating and like I should not be speaking
to this but don't you think that if you
did look at somebody's Instagram before
a date you would start to come up with
like ideas about them and who they are
and you might like just naturally
dislike them whereas if you met them in
person and it was more of a Slow blow
and you learned about it from them like
you have more of a shot at liking that
person yeah but maybe you're not
supposed to like them no and also you
want to look at tagged photos you want
to see them not in the photos they post
other people's posts but eventually
let's suppose you like them right and
then afterwards you see their Instagram
and that is also another kind of
disappointment where you're like [__]
their social media presence is so cringe
lot of so which is better to know
upfront that their social media is
cringe or to know after you've already
started liking them everyone on the apps
has been single for 50 years and they
need to [__] figure this out and stop
finding ways to finding problems in
people and just like fall in love with
someone I don't know I'm like all my
friends on the
apps I get that it sucks and it's really
hard but I just hear them nitpick about
like the worst like littlest things
where I'm like oh yeah if I paid
attention to that like of course I
wouldn't have gone further with Dave
it's like people are just I think
soy yeah I I deleted hard on everybody I
deleted my Rya for that exact reason
because I because Andrew Keegan didn't
match it's exactly why guys Andrew what
the hell is going
on what the H there's nothing not to
want in this situation get your ass on
here we'll get you chicken strips are
you vegan we'll get you fake chicken
strips get your ass over here you want
to furky we'll get you some [__] T
Fury you might even leave with a
girlfriend
hello it really is a y 2K episode when
you're
mentioning I'm
livid on that note eser do you want to
close his out Happy Thanksgiving in a
month we're having it early cuz we're
hungry and
hormonal um wait I have more to say oh
no this I want to see the shoes a guy is
wearing before I go on a date with them
okay because there's a type of shoe game
that I'm not that doesn't work for me
you sound psycho to me
you're it's a style it's that's not a
connection I'm sorry going to fall in
love then I'm in love but we're talking
in a world for people who aren't I age I
was that was when I was dating there's a
certain I don't want to deal with going
to a place and I have no vibe with some
I go to the date and then I'm there
having no vibe how about I see that he's
wearing weird moccasins and I'm [__]
out honestly that should be a dating
reality show of shoes there's types of
shoes I'm tell I totally agree what if
he shows up in jeans and leather sandals
like that's what I'm saying No this is
like but that's a very it depends where
you are cuz I feel like a lot of dudes
in Hawaii still you know an island
that's still kind of acceptable and then
but over here no no thank you but I
would I would accept it over there um
but you know that dating show that you
guys hate the naked attraction with
whatever it's called why obsessed with
it shut up obsessed I think there is
something I love the butt pimples I love
I love how regular how regular this
these people nobody's hot will you go on
it it is only if I didn't have to get
naked and I could just choose like I I I
wouldn't be no I wouldn't show my
[__] you know what I mean like I've
had surgery on my tits I feel like you
could find your soulmate by choosing
that way I love how they have uncut dick
I love everything about it it's just
it's very it is grotesque but I I like
how it's very harsh lighting so bright
yeah it's harsh
lighting everything is out and um yeah I
think there's something to it you know
it's a little unfair to the men I'm
going to be honest because there's a lot
of growers in this world they really are
and not a lot of
showers yeah because I thought about it
because one of a couple of the showers
on the show either they were they had
like were smart enough to jerk off and
have a half chub right before the
cameras were on or they were just
showers right but I I saw a couple of
the
[Laughter]
uncutsports
guys I I cannot believe I didn't tell
you this I went to a nude beach the
other day which one I went in a black in
a San Diego San Diego I was filming
during a bed obviously but
um
wow bodies are [__]
nasty nasty nasty bodies and nobody told
me I was like gonna have to like scale
them out and to get down there too it
was like to work that hard to see that
much disgusting coino and getting back
up
what and the way back up you're like
what have I done there was like a family
going down with kids I'm like should I
warn them they look European there was a
girl giving H to it was the nastiest
looking people I've ever seen just
because it's a it's a nude beach doesn't
mean that it like sex is allowed I don't
think no I felt wrong yeah especially
when I was you know pushing her head
further
in okay wait can I just say though that
I have friends this is not about the
nude beach this is about dating stop
there
we don't believe you prove it I have
friends who like prioritize height in a
partner and I'm like I feel like you
these people would rather date like a
tall bad partner than a short good
partner correct that's correct I played
a game with on Leah's show where it was
are they hot or are they tall there so
many mid tall guys that get like really
hot girls and they just get them because
they're tall I quite disagree I don't
like super looking at Super tall guys
naked I almost have like a phobia I
respect you for that you're different
yeah I don't height is whatever but I I
do have girl friends who are um bigger
girls who are basically like no I need a
bigger guy because I'm a bigger girl and
I like to feel like the smaller one
reles feel better to have a person that
is bigger than you what are the parts on
a man that really like what are like
your
what hands calves hands calves those
parts love Dave's deformed hands they're
so hot they're so hot hands are a huge
thing for me really I feel like and I've
said this on the show um before um send
me handpicks that's my that's my porn
like it's wow it's so sexy to me the
veins the
forarms yeah everything about it I love
hands you need to like go back to
nursing in school that's so weird the
veins you never dated anyone that's in a
push-up in their life I don't want
people to have
veins what I want to cut into your skin
and you be a Barbie like veins are so
scary veins are scary get her please get
her veins are scary kind of a vain thing
to say don't you think sure she said I
don't like veins I want to cut into your
skin like a Barbie but I'm an [__]
because I don't want you wearing a a
flip-flop from the farmers market that
could be your hand Whitted I I don't
want it that could be your my soulmate
Annie I think that's brilliant it's not
my soulmate she's wrong no there's no
way no if someone was wearing like a
slipper that would make me break up with
Todd sell are out for you out and if
you're wearing the wrong sneaker with
the wrong pant forget about it here's
the thing style is always purchasable
you can always change the style that's
true and I've dressed up many a
man yeah I think that is something if
they're open to it but if you're willing
to wear the type of sandal I'm thinking
about right now will never it's never
going to work out especially those type
of guys don't want you to dress them
they're trying to prove some point or
something no you know what disappoints
me I'm not saying I would break up it's
disappointing is it veins is it blood
running through people's bodies it's
disappointing when it's not boxing
oh what what that's a hot take I would
say boxers boxers are so not in anymore
are you guys insane we also like veins
loose boxers for us I like wearing
boxers at home like I personally do are
we talking what we wear you talk about
tight boxer like Bo boxer briefs or you
talking Joe boxers boxer briefs are the
ones those are the ones no briefs are
the ones what are boxer brief brief no
briefs are like tight tight trunks no no
that's underwear
boxers are so that's a hot hot take are
you kidding me all of you you you you
you dirty [__] come on you like
boxers I'll take anything other than
tidy whes my dad I don't want dress like
my dad okay not tidy whes boxer briefs
at least can we agree on that obviously
the hot ones they're the tighter like
sliding shorts almost no that might as
well be tidy whes what no y'all are you
guys boxers are
I'm Ying I Am Britney today yes you are
crazy out of your goddamn mind I cannot
believe the reaction I'm getting I
thought everyone it was going to be like
a team moment honestly I I thought you
might have one person to agree with you
and I was thrilled when everyone looked
at you like you were I think we need to
take this to the streets cuz I'm I'm yes
we do YouTube comments boxers or boxer
Bo briefs are mine just cuz she wants to
wear them honestly it is a weird not
that it's hot a man in boxers that's
like to me that's like a woman in
lingerie like that's a hot iconic way to
see God it's so sloppy it's sloppy yeah
it's Lo and it bunches up under jeans
imagine that just bunching up doing well
you guys are she's unwell Annie oh my
God Happy Thanksgiving and also lingerie
on a girl are you still into
that you
loser you [__] loser you're a [__]
loser we got to listen guys write in the
comments who we can replace Esther with
I can't handle these [__] takes
anymore no your soulmate is out there
wearing foot flops and it's just it's
really sad I am married what are you
talking about to someone with a style
that matches me it worked out just fine
the way I did it I will tell you Todd is
the one of the only people I haven't had
to dress and I do appreciate relief that
is a i same with Bobby I and he wouldn't
want me to dress him until I like that
too I guess I do like Dave style I
definitely by the way definitely do not
like a guy who likes expensive stuff
like Dave is so like I need someone
who's
Frugal and doesn't think that they are
have self worth to spend money I love
honestly right now I had a return a fan
I got a one of those expensive uh Dyson
fans because I thought it would Todd
gets like allergies if I run a fan at
night and so I was like oh this won't
give him allergies but it gives him
allergies and it was $700 I'm like it's
the last day to return it and I gave
Todd my credit card to go to Sentry City
mall and let me tell you there buy a lot
of candy there's going to be not candy
there's going to be a very expensive
jacket I bet purchased Todd I like when
Todd gets a nice expensive jacket on me
really mhm that's cute I do like buying
Dave clothes and he's so appreciative
it's like sad it's actually so sad it's
so
sad oh God I think we're good right okay
okay everyone sorry we ate on mic but
we're humans guys we're humans we're
hormonal we were here a long time I live
so far
[Music]
with